une quinzaine de bateaux remontant la
Loire à contre-courant un spectacle
étonnant que vous pouvez voir en ce
moment et ce pour trois jours en
Loir-et-Cher la flotti fait
effectivement escale ce soir à Chaumont
sur Loire parti de Nantes le 1er
septembre elle doit rejoindre Orléans
pour les 20 ans du Festival de Loire à
bord des Marignan ambassadeurs du fleuve
mais aussi des artistes et scientifiques
Pierre-Alexandre Gèze a posé l'ancre à
Amboise
c'est à la force des bras et en luttant
contre le fleuve qu'une quinzaine de
bateliers ont jeté l'encre au pied du
château d'Amboise ces bateaux remontent
la Loire à contre-courant de Nantes à
Orléans où ils sont attendus pour
l'ouverture du Festival de la Loire le
20 septembre prochain alors d'ici là il
faut se retrousser les manches ce pas
physique bah il y a des endroits comme
ça où ils sont je dirais c'est plus
technique que physique les efforts
intenses sont vraiment assez courts
quand même bah heureusement que les
moteurs parce que sinon il faudrait
qu'on ait qu'on ait du vent qui soit
tout le temps dans le bon sens pour
pouvoir remonter ce qu'on a des voiles
carrées qui nous permettent que de
remonter en vente arrière comme
Pierre-Alexandre 80 bateliers ont
embarqué pour cette deuxième édition de
la Grande remontée une deuxième édition
étendue de 200 km par rapport à la
précédente et qui voit également des
scientifiques à bord
il y a de tout des qui étudie
l'environnement les sédiments ils font
partie des facultés de Nantes Angers
Tours Blois Orléans et des scientifiques
qui sont pas forcément en rapport avec
les biologies marines ou avec le fleuve
tout au long de ce périple ce beau monde
a su attirer les foules et ça pour le
plus grand plaisir des curieux et étant
passionné de photos on en a profité pour
pour prendre des photos de de la ville
du château des tous ces personnes qui
sont là donc c'est très agréable à
regarder très sympa la grande remontée
s'arrêtera tout au long du trajet
jusqu'à Orléans ou des marchés locaux et
des animations seront proposées